yeah but Superman doesn't mean prep time
no because he's crazy stronger that's
heat vision in frost oh my god
everybody's sitting that's why sir man's
got crazy as a tack of the world we all
gotta get ready wonder who are you ready
to go yeah I'm ready to go like flash
you're ready to go yeah man I'm ready to
go what about you side work yeah man I'm
gonna go to the watchtower everything's
gonna be what about you Batman wait wait
wait everyone Batman would not see
anywhere because here we go here's the
boss rivalries that way everybody wait
now wait now y'all need to give me like
ten minutes no no he would go like this
on y'all prep time don't worry
here's my anti Superman bag BB Batman
answer I'm head kryptonite ring that
time nude photos white that I can
blackmail on with his Twitter password
prepped
what's going on guys this is Rob and as
many of you may or may not know today is
Batman day why is it Batman day you ask
well four years ago DC decided to
celebrate the 75th anniversary of
Batman's debut in Detective Comics
number 27 and 1939 the thing is though
that book actually didn't come out until
May of 1939 but for some reason the
first Batman day was on July 23rd 2014
so not on the actual anniversary of his
debut then in 2015
Batman Day was moved to September and it
stayed there ever since for reasons that
I simply just cannot find an explanation
to but regardless of its dubious
scheduling we are celebrating Batman day
today and featuring Batman in our series
on Omega level and beyond Omega level
characters now right away let's discuss
the elephant in the room I know there
were lots of you guys out there who saw
the title of this video and were
probably confused I mean Batman does not
have any powers so how could he possibly
be an Omega level or beyond Omega level
character after all this series focuses
on the most powerful beings and comic
books well if that's what you were
saying when you saw this video pop up in
your feed then you would technically be
correct Batman does not have any actual
powers he's just a normal guy at least
until Dark Knight's metal concludes
which will probably tell us that
Batman's been super-powered this whole
time but I
I dress now since we don't actually have
any powers to cover in this video we're
going to be going into a discussion on
why it is that prep time gives Batman
such an advantage over his opponents so
the reason Batman is able to maximize
prep time is because he has two huge
advantages a superior intellect and a
seemingly inexhaustible wealth because
of these two factors Batman can look at
whatever threat comes his way even if
it's an opponent that he can never
defeat on his own and use his
intelligence to figure out a way to
defeat them and then use the vast
resources at his disposal to make that
solution a reality and we've seen him do
this on several occasions throughout his
history for instance we know that Batman
created brother AI which is a global
surveillance artificial intelligence
network that allows him to gather tons
of data about all the super humans on
earth now while Batman does not have
omniscience we know that he is capable
of somewhat replicating this concept
through his ability to create such an
extensive surveillance network that
allows him to basically see anything he
wants at any particular point in time
now another thing that we've mentioned
before on this channel is that Batman
has actually been able to take down the
Justice League after using his resources
to construct an armor that would allow
him to exploit their various weaknesses
this happened around the beginning of
the in-game storyline of Scott Snyder's
run on Batman and as part of that story
we saw Batman using the armor that he
had created to take down the members of
the Justice League who had all been
influenced by the Joker toxin now this
armor cost Batman an amount greater than
60% of the money that the world nations
spent on their entire militaries and
used a variety of tools to take down the
Justice League for example they'd used
an object known as the bind of veils a
mythical object created by Hephaestus to
counteract Wonder Woman's lasso of truth
in order to basically defeat her to
neutralize the flash he used a
super-fast computer to track the Flash's
movements and sprayed a frictionless
coating in his path he coded
Aquaman with a substance that absorbed
all the moisture from his body and built
miniaturized red suns into the armors
knuckles and used a gun filled with
kryptonite particles to take down
Superman so what we actually see from
this is that Batman is smart enough to
prepare for almost
every possibility and eventually given
enough time then you'll also be able to
acquire or buy anything he needs to be
victorious now in addition to this we've
seen Batman battle some of the most
powerful characters of the DC Universe
and survived because he's so greatly
increased his durability through the
body armor that he has at his disposal
and Superman Batman number 28 for
example Batman is beaten badly by what
he believes to be the Martian Manhunter
but is actually an alien known as Zook
that is mimicking the Martian Manhunter
powers even so taking a beating from
someone as powerful as Martian Manhunter
it's pretty much the same as taking a
beating from Superman and surviving
without any ill effects and an Infinite
Crisis number one Batman is struck by
the supervillain Mongol who's been shown
at times to have strength greater than
that of Superman and Batman simply gets
back up and keeps on fighting so what
does all this proof well the body armor
the Batman wears is clearly a product of
his prep time he has designed the armor
and had it made for him and while
wearing it he's able to take damage from
some of the heaviest hitters in the DC
Universe meaning that he can pretty much
make himself indestructible so while I
think that we can all agree that in a
very literal sense batman is obviously
not omega-level not even close even when
you take into account all his special
skills his expertise in hand-to-hand
combat his detective skills and even the
infinite tech Engadget tree he's
employed over the years while those
things do make him an extremely
formidable fighter he still doesn't even
register anywhere close to Omega level
but as the most hardcore Batman fans
will attest when you add in the secret
ingredient of prep time that's when
everything changes prep time takes
Batman from a guy to a guy who can
seemingly dismantle the entire Justice
League a guy who can stand up to the
biggest most powerful villains in the DC
Universe and live to tell about it
a guy who can basically do anything he
wants because he's Batman and when you
have that kind of plot armor nothing can
take you down not even Darkseid's Omega
beams which have literally
old every ordinary human being that
they've ever come down on but when
you're Batman it just kind of sends you
back in time and it messes with your
memory a little bit because you're
Batman and DC cannot afford to kill you
off with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here two comments explain make
sure you guys have the sub button to
become part of the rob Court if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]